it can't get away from you but it's not
all glamorous as everyone thinks it is
you know I mean a lot of people and I
don't even like the bird it's like the
look at the Fame side of things and I
don't like it because that's not what I
do a job for
I don't class myself as famous never
once thought I am and never ever will
I'm a flower from Newcastle who's been
lucky enough to follow his dream and
does a job that he wants to do and I
keep telling myself up because 99% of
the population doesn't get to do us even
at the start the year wasn't that I hit
some sort of depression or anything like
that but I felt like I was losing my
mind because I've came back from tour
and I just couldn't adjust back to
normality it wasn't like normal life
that's couldn't get round the jet lag so
you taught in three four days with
absolutely no sleep whatsoever and I was
going on like nighttime drives and like
this voice in my head started coming
more and more I was kind of like the
only really gonna go of sleepers by
smashing you can't that lorry across
there or things like that and that's
when I started think heleng2 something
wrong
ladies and gentlemen welcome back I've
managed to get a hold of him Christoph
thanks waited if I should have you
wanted much to grab you in between
firearm indeed sorry for the delay
I've been trying to get this sorted for
hair right now forever that's the way
they've been recently whoever got you
from a merit girl
predominately the hall of the Simone men
the last bit there was America South
America and then straight from there for
me last Shauna Bertha which was their
one hell of a journey type of thing
worth and we've just said just before
we've started you've had to take a call
to saw how India yeah I have Australia
around the UK for the next few weeks and
then literally go from here to America
back here to India to New Zealand to
Australia to Bali to Australia to back
yet and then eventually come home I
think when I say yeah I mean like the UK
yeah yeah it's there should be good and
I'll pretend to insist that was away for
Christmas so she was kicking up everyone
oh yeah I just joke now go back to
America fear for new young stuff like
that
yeah so I've got if it a down payment
dissemble which I don't know if I want
or not I was gonna say what did it feel
like on you slow down now because let me
see like the whole dream a lot of people
will be some DJ's that are listening
some promoters or the people that know
the party world and they see that DJ
flying around the world playing their
own tracks you know getting aid to
travel and see all these different
places what does it feel like when you
slow down now and to be honest with you
I like my team always make me take time
off and I'm always kind of reluctant to
do so then towards the end of say the
six weeks that you've been on tour
something you begin to realize that you
are running on fumes and it's just the
adrenaline getting you through and I
mean I was looking at this you know
yourself through promoting people pay
serious money for ages and people pay
serious money to get into clubs and to
buy the drinks and things like that
especially in the likes of abathur and
stuff so if you ought to turn up with
what our classes are fierce like a smart
dose you know what I mean it's gonna it
goes out to the crowd and the crowd look
back and think it's not
[ __ ] ass the Pope he's not interested
at all when really it's just doing a bit
tired us or so Paul's trying be is
upbeat as I can't when I'm not really
one of those DJs who stands there and
gives it all the hands and you know
dancer now you're a guru vaak your guru
they are a dancer yeah so I try and just
be there in interrupt with the promoters
the crowd afterwards and things like
that so as I see you you do realize that
you are running on adrenaline and on
fumes and stuff like that so you think
wait I'll get back then I get home and I
can't sleep because of the jetlag I'm
really really bad with it you cannot
come down with like a flu because of all
the the em like they've been on the
planes with the aircon and stuff like
that a really powerful always come down
with some sort of flu and I get through
that so the past week that's what I've
been button with now I'm still a little
bit tired but I'm [ __ ] bored on my
you know I'm just trying to haul off
from God in the studio now I'm just like
right I'm definitely right in the truck
this week so I'll probably going
tomorrow Friday and get something done
and I just want to be back on the road
the games just like you know what I mean
oh my mates all loved up I'm slightly a
single just twiddling my thumbs and I'm
a time like I'm gonna get put up really
close yeah didn't you used to really be
bad with flying yeah mate Errol so
remember when we went out to abathur and
you were I think it was about midday in
maybe 2013 someone like that middle of
the season and you were sinking a couple
of pints there's a you're getting on it
a little bit early and your thing was no
this is just so I can kind of get on the
plane and not feel too EF table yeah I
think like the whole drinking beforehand
used to really relaxes and you get to
that point where you don't really care
that much now it's a second nature I
mean I still do panic when you gone all
across the Atlantic and you hit major
turbulence and stuff like that but it's
I've got this voice in my head which
keeps on telling us that the planes
going down and I'm all you and I've kind
of bypass the whole turbulence thing
because I'm all doing the voice in my
head but yeah but yeah I mean it's like
I just realized that it is work it's
what I've got to do
to climb the ladder and to reach the
dreams which I've set myself type of
thing and I'm still not a hundred
percent comfortable with it and I don't
think many people are it's just
something that you have to do
I'm very unnatural yet being being in a
plane yeah 35,000 feet my doctor tells
me that all the time
they all the time you just like it's not
normal for you to sit on planes for as
much as you do for as long as you do as
many times of the years you do yeah you
know I mean the pressure on you and
things like that but as I seem it's
works I get it so by way of starting a
little bit of an origin story for you I
think one of the things that I've quite
selfishly probably enjoyed about being
able to see the trajectory of your
career is I got to spend a lot of time
with you like ten years ago yeah we were
both parking in New York so we were
playing gigs together and you've played
for some of my events just as you know
little normal local gigs and then I've
seen that trajectory as it's climbed up
and climbed up and how you've got to the
place that you are now where you're
supporting Eric Prince on New Year's Eve
and releasing tracks on his on his
record label when 10 years ago you would
be talking about him with the same kind
of starry-eyed fan bonus that everybody
else does yes and seeing that trajectory
seeing you go from being a DJ of which I
know hundreds yeah to being those of
which I know like maybe to maybe you and
Patrick topping yeah the only two guys
who are even really close to that kind
of like there's a few coming up with
Newcastle me there's some good ones I
mean which you've done well I don't know
him yeah all right FEM yeah yeah it's a
hot spot isn't it for DJ Tanner it isn't
it honestly like a lot of people are
starting to seal it what's in the water
up in the Northeast now she'll say the
Northeast because there's only to form
actually Newcastle you know the rest of
my family all from you custom so can you
just give us a little bit of how would
you define your career love you good
question
um I don't really know I mean ever since
I've been a young kid out of DJ my dad
was a DJ my brother was a DJ so it's
kind of been in the family it's all I've
ever wanted
do but actually understand in the whole
of the industry and how I would get
there I didn't really have a plan didn't
understand it whatsoever I mean we were
just sat around and I'll be like oh yeah
I'm gonna be a DJ that type of crack do
you know what I mean everyone's like oh
cause you're me and then air it actually
talked sadly like one of my friends
passing away he just died out the blue
her too thick do you know I mean and I
think just basically he's took too many
like painkillers and too short a period
of time by accident and body's just shut
down type of thing and that just give me
a massive kick up loss it's that whole
cliche that could happen to anyone and I
just was just like right the only way
I'm gonna kind of reach these goals
which you want to but you've set
yourself in life type of thing is by
like learning to produce now I can't
play an instrument only think like that
I just still know that trumpet
now like consider learning the piano I
really do like pianos both and you can
obviously pass it on in the keyboard and
sit there with your MIDI keyboard but I
find it easy just to draw in on Ableton
on the piano rule what I want to do and
solves loops it and make one bars two
bars four bars whatever and start
writing my patterns and messing around
and fortunately I know what kind of
works on the dance floor because I've
been in that many nightclubs and go of
that much and stuff like that and know
exactly what I want to make for what
time in the night and things like that
and just went from there really your
foundation is a club DJ playing like
high volume a lot of nights a lot like
time and attention yes that has created
a good base yeah without without yeah
without without I mean for a DJ and
alone some of the nights that I used to
when I work for you guys take this thing
I'll be teaching for six hours from
10:00 to 4:00 whatever like out of five
hours 10 plus 3 or 9 or 3 whatever it
was and and that has taught me a lot
what I need to know reading the crowds
seen what's going on seen what to play
doing your homework on it and making
your sub like sex
sound different anybody else out there
you know what I mean like homing in on
certain areas and things I mean
Newcastle has been a city where but
dominantly it's been without being
around it's been R&B pop music which has
been the big sound but there was a huge
surge of house music that funky house
stuff which caused the phone
yeah like the head candy style and
everything like that everything beyond
sound as playing up and out that morning
time I was sitting [ __ ] hell like
this big competition out there cuz at
one point I was literally the only DJ in
Tom who was playing host music so then
you've got it kind of look I don't think
right what's working how can I get
myself some problems how can I make my
set different to theirs and stuff like
that so that's when you start looking at
making like a bootleg a mash-up type of
thing and going from there but yeah like
the old saying without a doubt that the
whole long set thing working for five
six hours is really honed in on the DJ
and side of things and helped you like
help me become a lot better addict type
of thing and reading a crowd more yeah
so there's a guy called James Smith is a
famous online PT now yeah and he talks a
lot about the fact that he cut his teeth
doing like 10,000 hours of on flop
eating right and he's now transitioned
that and his abilities that he's learned
doing like the grunt work yeah of just
normal everyday stuff and now he's
distilled that down and it's kind of the
same thing
[ __ ] and if you completed took to
Palace on a Friday in the middle of
December 150 people in there that what's
Creamfields main stage so one of the
things that you touched on there which
there's a few elements of your career
that I absolutely love and again I've
had this weird voyeuristic ability to
see it so close-up yeah which is rare so
I'm taking the opportunity to kinda get
to indulge myself a little bit one of
the things I really enjoyed although
it's a [ __ ] nightmare for me at that
as a promoter is that you would never
compromise your sets no and I don't want
any DJs that are listening if you don't
play for me follow that way if you play
for me I do not [ __ ] listen it's a
nightmare
but one of my favorite stories of ours
is when we played in a beat this so we
took you out to be to twice I think you
actually give you first ever gig in
space remember also yes in the TX was
yeah so I mean it's off was the second
is that the sensor so the terrace was
when you when you finished corrector
thing yeah and then the second time we
played a big bowl party and the after
party was in amnesia cetera yes in the
main Sara's fan but the way that it
worked like typically anyone who's ever
been to a beat the 10 o'clock at night
in Ibiza is a ghost town
yeah no one's I took the cleaners and
that the like roadie Tex but what
happened to us he had these 10 bolts
each filled with like 200 people yeah
and they'd all been steaming from 6:00
p.m. we're all straighten at the club
and they just fill this room so very
bizarrely your opening set was like a
2:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m. 4:00 a.m. I had to
really be hard head straight away and
anyway right fine had you and someone
else and someone else lined up to play
this thing and this room starts filling
up and filling up and I'm like so he's
playing his vibe that's cool and one of
the guys comes over the promote comes
over and says we're gonna have to get
into like I give you know Chanyeol a
hi-fi but the way that you do when you
feel I don't know how far I could push
you I was like and then sure enough like
three minutes later because they're
expecting like you know the big house
this year 2012 they're expecting us we
shall smell fear and stuff oh yeah
Thank You Morgan it's like no he's still
not pushing enough and I was like right
come back over to you again same thing
happens notes you a third time and he
was just like right [ __ ] it
the next guy can come on a dog I'm not
bothered yeah and I was like that was
probably the first time an amnesia
playing on a Jew yellow on the terrace
2500 people losing their [ __ ] that all
hammered like perfect crowd and rather
than you delve in you create somewhere
to pick out some bangers that you
probably would have had floating around
you could have played from back in the
day your thing was I'll just I'll walk
off yeah and I just put someone else on
yep my favorite story yeah
really like this it's sounds stupid but
there's always a reason for it and I'm
thinking of the future I'm thinking of
the bigger picture now
then were wanting to push it to I don't
know see the BPM up to one through two I
would have been at 122 123 do you not I
mean so the jump up there you can't
remember that there's other DJ's to come
on here while the headliners of that
Club who will be coming on from say 1:00
2:00 in the morning
now if they'll step into the booth from
the kid who was on before them this
little unknown [ __ ] is playing at
1:32 they're gonna be like what the [ __ ]
is going on here yeah kick off complain
and they're gonna come at you to tell
you slow it down do you know what I mean
and in my world those are the guys who I
want to meet so if I was if I'm always
like start on a bad foot of them and
then remember me for the kid who was
playing too fast and was playing a load
of [ __ ]
instead of playing a warm-up set for
them you're already gonna be someone who
that don't really want to sushi it with
Jim I mean it was a brand new world out
there to me what I was trying to get
into and I was just thinking think about
the like the long run this is just like
a little warm-up gig to a bunch of kids
who up off the [ __ ] head do you know
what I mean them I better remember it so
I mind the guy come across to me at the
bombs just like look I'm sorry for see I
said look you've got a club to run but
I've also got a career to start and he
bought me a shot myself guarantee I'll
be back to headline your club and I
think was maybe the year after the year
after that I've done with defected and
but and you stumpy [ __ ] well I think
fully like believe that that's what I
would do do you know what I mean and
it's kind of that like the whole
believing in yourself and I knew that
was like the big picture and knew that
was my aim and I knew what I was going
to be doing and I wouldn't jeopardize it
by playing [ __ ] show me love or
something like that that it would have
went off and I'm sure the kid who come
on after his that was you first saw yeah
like in a hook the whole place went off
and I all right I could have cleared
that but not doing that could have also
jeopardized whatever the whole
we could have [ __ ] it up I think I
think Nathan Williams actually played a
Backstreet Boys remix of deep house I
think that's when I left the privilege
so even going back like again indulging
myself further about some good memories
remember when we went to Lane 7 for
Michael's birthday and Pete Tong played
your track on Radio 1 in the evening oh
yeah or lbm yeah like these sorts of
things like is even then like I was that
would that have been like maybe Pepsi or
big H or something like that would have
not been even before that time that's
all for probably I was Google where's
our shelter or something yeah so what I
know the ones that started getting on
the rear of your first first real big
truck
yeah but this still at that stage you
were still like essentially like a local
legend yeah yeah so how would you get
from being a guy who once has Pete on
play a track on a Friday well what
happens between that point and flying
around literally spending your life on
planes paying the biggest gigs on the
plan your kisses as good as mine I think
a lot of it is being in the right place
at the right time and I do I do think
that I mean that with the right sound
yes I mean my sound has changed a lot
since those days but I've always known
what I was doing and I was always making
more of this progressive melodic sound
and and it wasn't really getting
anywhere because it's such a niche
market so I realized that right what
I've got to do was kind of delve into
the more tech your stuff which is really
bubbling it's getting all the big crowds
and what everyone started to play maybe
make a few hits and not to create a base
following and then stop going slowly
back to Allah because I didn't bringing
them in that was the whole kind of
business plan type within that I had it
worked really well because it was a
period where you were quite tightly tied
in the heart since 82 rows yeah yeah I
mean I was I still am a huge fan of
dearly and I'm saying with with the same
manager as him and stuff like that but
again they just didn't fully get the
or progressive vibe and that's fair
enough to know him I don't know if they
didn't enjoy it or what I don't know but
it was kind of like all of a sudden Eric
start with like stumble across kotse he
liked the song yeah and that was the
last truck on a truck which I've done
for daily which is like this conceptual
album project that were done and Eric
could create that on his epic radio show
yeah and I'd seen it someone had said
some things I've seen it and I was in
America at the time and I was actually
meant to play le and on the flight on
the way over the gig got canceled
because the week before there was a
fight in the club so I've got me in the
promo said the gigs off so I had a few
chunks of the preneur then flew off and
I was tilling off weeks later I was
still in America playing my last show in
Chicago on a Saturday night and Eric was
actually doing two like charity shows
for a guy called James Lyle or little
who passed away and and he was doing
them at the club I was meant to be
playing in LA now on the first one by
all accounts the guy who was on before
played all Eric's trucks
so he was pissed off about that this guy
who manages the club sound in LA
contacted my manager at the time said
look does Chris wanna fly back and warm
up farik we all know he's a bigger rig
fan so that Ron and I said look you've
got a pay for your own flight across to
LA from Chicago
then a new one home from LA you've got
to pay for your own accommodation but
you do get the warm-up for your hero so
notice I may never ever get that
opportunity again so went across played
and I ended on cut C and he turn around
to Renee's tour manager said for [ __ ]
sake I wanted to clear his truck and
many was like that's Chris and then [ __ ]
you for me and Eric started talking it
was like get my number off Rennie we've
got things to discuss about and then the
next day the rang up and said like the
wanna play epic five and then it just
went from [ __ ] zero to a hundred like
overnight
that's going on so like what does it
feel like so cuz I don't think that we
can really convey to the listeners just
how big of a fan you were
very afraid still perfect isn't it like
it you tell me a story like after
parties your mate to take the piss out
of you for talking about how fun boy you
were about oh yeah completely and back
up those boys I started seeing things to
whine their male seeing oh yeah I'll
clear Eric Prydz to note I mean like
just to get them a bite and when they
were pissed you know me like shut up and
like just like lads but a type of thing
but you hear me I remember once we write
a party I'm sat there and i said would
anyone cover Creamfields and everyone
was like yeah yes i sat bought for their
Creamfields tickets so right you come to
Creamfields tomorrow [ __ ] watch print
that's all we're doing were just driving
down remember that what just throw him
in there the kids were just stood in his
tent all day what's Jeremy Orlando yours
for mere Jim calls Eric come on finish
walk straight back to the condo straight
back home it was think that there yeah
that had got rained off on the Sunday
they will come safe thought it was
[ __ ] pissing down me freezing cold
we've got Ross Walton that drive so he
cooked down had a few drinks in worth
from about five or six in the night to
stopping and he just ate hot dogs all
the way till it was like 11:00 that
night and then we were late right lure
off by rather school yeah for there yeah
Amy I mean I will follow him everywhere
everywhere everywhere code I would go
and see him and just constantly just
this plate listen with music non-stop
non-stop nothing else would ever ever
this is still now so I mean how long
have you been working in collaboration
with Eric now it's just over two years
okay when you get a text often so I
think we were in we were somewhere in
Newcastle and you were like I think he
texted you
yeah what happens when you see the name
Eric pretty pop up on your phone do you
still go like yeah you get they get it
so we had butterfly feeling and at one
point I think that he's just gonna go
right I've had enough you're off other
jobs over me
yeah pretty much so and then the others
it's just like [ __ ] hell I think
actually a student one of my good
friends tape a thing on top of like
working alongside him so it's more than
than not it's just stupid
Buckner between was yeah because like I
mean we've been touring a hell of a lot
together this summer hmm
and so heels like say for instance we've
just been up to Sweden which was amazing
to see him and his hometown of all these
old friends and everything layout and
how big was a club maybe we were played
this place called f12 and I'd actually
done a track called f12 and I've seen
interviews with him and he says like if
any the last club you would ever want to
play
he always says f12 so sickness is gonna
be [ __ ] in this club I expect it to be
small like underground things they are
me its steps outside of a building
that's what it is that's the club it's
the strangest [ __ ] thing of ever
feeling like we have it cooked so
marginally in olds Trent like a
government build okay yes we were in
sight there's a bar inside and a little
club down says but the DJ proofing is
they got the end of the boss or I'm
trying to think of a club in town which
is that would when I had that kind of
see him set up it's just a pair of decks
at the end of a bar so we were outside
and literally honestly maybe there was a
window there and this was scarcely not
gonna have to climb out and you climb no
and you were in between people's legs
who were dancing on a windowsill yeah to
cut them out the way climb up with it
exelon a window sort of jump into the DJ
booth to play and those just two sets of
stairs coming up and to set asides a
stairs as I was saying those bars at the
top of the enema big is it may I was
probably said I thought was about 200
people right but they were just like now
that was about four or five hundred
there but I was like there must have
been a canny few stone on that with me
or do people just found it dancing on
stairs of his sermon laterally to
started that mean the atmosphere was
unreal so we got hammered a an hour flew
back to London to play London and then
flew back to Gothenburg met when
Gothenburg and he just let me go in
there
great Gothenburg and I had a great laugh
there and he woke up the next day and I
think he was a bit hungover and he took
a picture at the barn he's gone can't
stop that was it can't stop won't stop
with something that knows it and then he
took a fix of their vows and I was just
in hysterics and he's just keeps on
because I was laughing at him he keeps
on doing it whenever we've been putting
a few gigs he'll take a picture at me I
need it like a hair of the dog to have a
thing he's gets to go yeah
and he's just cracks me up when he's a
funny bus that mate really is that's
awesome hey wait again like to see
someone that I care about get to live
the dream out with you know it's such a
perfect storm it seems to me like I
remember that in white rooms bootleg
that you did yeah a decade ago uh-huh
and like it was mint but you know like
to go from that from like just [ __ ]
about with stems and really rare tracks
to this is a real real testament to the
way you were and again to kind of for
DJ's or artists that are listening one
of the things that I think I've noticed
that defines what you've done if you've
always stuck to your guns with regards
to what route you've been going in you
haven't compromised on that and then the
other thing has been you worked right
like yeah I remember an obsessive level
of sort of work even back in the day
like when you'd have gone when after
party and then walking up the next day
and if it was at yours everyone still be
downstairs partying but you'd be
upstairs Julia cracking she's doing
exactly the same is it yeah I try and do
at least one truck a week and if I don't
want something with a truck if I don't
actually do a full truck and then every
makes happy yeah and if I don't I really
get up myself and like say it yourself
like you throw a huge opportunity way
you've been lazy type of thing which I
don't think is maybe the healthiest of
attitudes to have but it works for me
and it gives us a case that's right
though your hair kick it gives us a kick
applause some of them are safe and I'll
just be late RA is fooling AB input I
don't dwell on something for too long
mmm I know a lot of producers out there
not like I get sent hell of a lot of
music and reply to every single person
who sends as a truck which is also very
time consuming
and we also have got quite a bit of time
on oh that's what I say it like I say
look make sure it's a streamable link
because when I'm sat in an airport I've
got nothing else to do I travel on my
own I haven't got a tour manager I'd do
everything on my own
so what else am I gonna do do you not I
mean sit in them everywhere around then
once you've been everywhere once when
you go back and it's like in your area
again you can see you imagine I've got
absolutely no idea how Tim the big about
taught you after this but now I am yes I
get I get sent a lot me and I go through
everything and you know like I try and
tell everyone like cuz a lot of them are
what would you change what would you do
I see like if I'm telling you what I
would do it then starts becoming my
truck do you know what I mean it's
you've got to believe in yourself you've
got to do what you do and don't sit
there because what ends up happening
there just throw the kitchen sink and
it's just you put too much into it and
it's that all see unless is more
definitely a definitely a character
characterization of your music I think
yeah and certainly that more melodic
sound which you're right there was there
was that period where you had a little
bit more sort of driving stuff yeah I
guess you'd be able to say and but I
knew there was always that bit in the
back of your mind it was like you just
wanted to get straight back into the
melody yeah and those kind of like
really ethereal kind of aplia like what
I'm trying to do what this moment is
bridge them together so I've got the
drive and because I find some
progressive to floor it yeah and it's
just standing there and I know for a
fact it's not what people are want not
2:00 in the morning you know what I mean
it's just kind of late great for apple
pie yeah it's like food and stuff like I
love it
drive around listening to it all the
time I found God hobbies or something
like knit massif ah whatever
yeah I'm done you know but like when I'm
in a club I want to hear some like makes
you move I like definitely made heads
down and the the melodic side of it is
what cut like capture the emotion so
when people are stuck there and the
breakdowns all this euphoric thing you
know what I mean that's what and you'll
start seeing them were the highs closed
and all it's like that's what you aim
and they get and that's why people leave
and the remember those records type of
thing they're not gonna remember
something which has just got a so boom
bit I think it's all a bit like rip
minsu boom bass although it's so based
type of thing with a two minutes
narrowed you know I mean they're not
gonna remember that
not at all because everything just
sounds the same so you've got a kind of
like make this really catchy melody all
this huge breakdown and that's what
gives the experience and that's what I
want to hear what I'm on the dance floor
so you play for yourself except I
selfishly I suppose I just as well that
you're not into like like ska punk let's
see how you play this a really to nobody
and out of all of the tracks that you've
seen played live what's the one that's
made people get the most emotional yours
or someone else's any memories in the
mind in particular of periods where
people have fully lost their [ __ ] I've
dropped down Spectras remix of a mystery
mystery land which is on Kevin and Perry
and it's like an old trance truck and
stalling me and this is like a proper
techno version of it and I've seen some
people like [ __ ] because I think it just
reminds them of Kevin and Harry - yeah
that's always a one which hits home
dopers must do yeah i live but it does
me it really does you see some asking
someone actually get down and get
engaged that Queen feels [ __ ] serious
smells like don't know if it is that one
this song's gonna last 10 minutes make
Bank goods for the rest of your life I
tamam it makes you awesome like some
crackers generally like that under the
sheets are always gets people going he
just dropped that last trap in the last
type of the night yeah but I think
that's more in towards the couples as if
they like get home it's a place just
like sex and a truck really enough it's
unbelievable our record one quality so
you mentioned that you do have a tour
manager not actually what what's the
reason for that and I'm not desperate
need for one well I haven't been until
recently and now the longer they are the
more you actually need that human
interruption because she said how much
is a tour manager friends that's just
there with you is that a significant
part just to be calm yeah I mean the
whole idea of a to a monitor someone who
deals little deal with your flights will
deal with any complications where the
flights delays and cancellations
anything like that no deal with the
driver picking you up or drive light
will deal with all the hotels like
checking in checking out things like
that
the deal will the promoters you are just
fully in the music game that's all you
just think neither pop you said what
you're gonna play and things like that
even when you get to the club if two
months and we'll go up to the decks and
cue everything up with your USB you
don't tell them what track you're gonna
start with that's what I've seen them do
type of things so that's what I'm
guessing is their job it's not something
I've really looked into I've got a bunch
of friends who want to do it trust them
them to do it is a comp somebody sounds
like the question that's gonna say I
know I'm your friends mate and exactly I
don't have made me their one of the
whole issues is I don't know come
without trust us two together
do you know I know oh the employing
like someone to comport you with us
that's what I would essentially be doing
because none of the morally massively
clued up in the music world which is
fair enough I don't expect them to be it
would be the company that I'm paying for
now that's when you asking how much that
is just something between you and them
I guess you can set up and give them a
salary and out of that them have got to
get the wrong travel or you give them
certain amount per tour and you just
employ them put to us I think there's a
lot of different ways you can work with
to amount of job see people just use
them for certain areas of the world like
Publix got Morgan look Morgan Bennett
yeah and I think he actually started off
just like the long ones they want to
over in America but by all comes I'm
sure he's doing the lot of them with him
know you've got to be with someone who
you get on with because you're basically
living in each other's pockets apart for
money in the hotel room now that's
another reason why I won't want to sit
in a hotel room on my own it's like a
real issue of going out and getting out
and if you've been partying and been
drinking and you've got late nights it
becomes harder to leave the room even if
it's just to go to the gym or downstairs
to the restaurant yeah sure it's just
kind of I've got this thing and I've
always had it where it takes
self-confidence thing which is quite
strange in the job that I do but you
think that everyone stare or not in like
you're sitting down on your own and you
think that everyone's talking about you
in you've gone to the gym on your own
and you think oh so you got shopping and
things like that so if it gets to a
point where I'm not feeling mentally
strong I'll just use like room service
and I'm on me in ciliate and then once
you've done that for two days and you
just locked and like essentially those
walls and then you've gone through
security in an airport model plane and
then back to another hotel and then the
only time you leaving it is to go and
get pissed while you DJ and type of
thing it then becomes a really weird
like like situation take your thing if
you were with someone you'd be how I
let's go out and we'll go watch the shot
so we'll go out for some food or
something like that we've got each other
to divide off and you don't realize your
surroundings as much one thing I've been
thinking of recently so I spend a lot of
time on my own as well yeah and I think
that as humans we desire conversation we
desired not conversation we desire a
dialogue yeah with an in the interaction
with other people other things and one
of the things that I've thought of
recently is if you're not around with
the people I think the dialogue begins
to just continue inside of your head oh
yeah
and I certainly feel when I spend too
much time in solitude that that inner
dialogue starts to turn up little outlet
oh yeah a little bit completely
I mean I always talk to myself to be
honest I admit but I know exactly what
you mean
I live alone I travel alone so and it's
a lonely life out there and I don't
think people realize that side of it
because they'll just look on and they'll
think oh he's flying around the world he
gets to see everywhere you see nothing
because you get in somewhere and you'll
get some food you'll try and get an
hour's sleep because you know you're
gonna be DJ until four or five in the
morning more than like you're going off
the pot engage in there till 9:00 10:00
in the morning then you think [ __ ] I've
got a flight in an hour - so you've got
to get back to the hotel pack your
suitcase straight on so no sleep your
brother now on the flight you know get
into somewhere you'll meet the promote
are you'll organizing them you'll get
another oh I'm bad you've got to get up
you sort your music and any of the next
one and when that's four or five days
and a roommate it's hard to keep control
of you of your mind and your thoughts
and stuff right up and it's just it
can't get away from you but it's not all
it's glamorous as everyone thinks it is
you know I mean but you don't be people
out there be like we don't need the coat
enough the party my mom says all the
time you don't need to go they don't
need the book when you're in there and
the Adrenaline's rushing and you've had
such a good gig and you look out and so
many people have bought a ticket to come
and see and the one on me in the one a
common part we really want to get to
know you and you get interested inside
of their lives and what it's like where
you are you know like in Argentina or
Chile or Brazil or Colombia whatever
like it's completely different we're
life down there it's it is interesting
to see how they go on and down
especially down outside the world like
music is their release from their life
type of thing you know what I mean it's
it's it the apps the comment of
thousands two gigs in everything's sold
out and that just completely the marsh
crowd in the world it's unbelievable
Tony
honestly like I keep on coming back in
confidence to myself that I'm gonna end
up buying somewhere no to tea and I'm
just having a house down there but when
you get there and you can plan in the
winter Tony may be used to it from being
up here oh hi
so you've touched on there the fact that
teach-ins maybe not as glamorous as
everyone
think since I might maybe not quite as
rosy we see was it last year that we had
Tim Burke Avicii passed away the year
before last year wasn't it yeah yeah
think that's Billy's one-year
anniversary this year
I was lose to I don't know enough it was
last year sure cuz then I'd might to up
one not two months of my itinerary guy
vanished to Eric's chill man answer
Rennie he's worked with Tim in the past
and I know Eric's was was good friends
with him and Sofia I'm sure I'll run
them lusts last year was to see if them
had seen type of thing see ya I think
when people saw the Avicii aftermath one
of the main things that came out was the
same one as when Robin Williams passed
away yeah which is you have someone who
appears to have everything going on they
have their [ __ ] together they have a
life that most people dream of it such
as cetera but look this is what can
happen and as tragic as it is one thing
that I do think is a positive that can
be taken from those situations is that
normal people who deal with levels of
anxiety or depression or dark dark days
and dark thoughts they get resented on
the fact I hang on if this guy who's a
world famous DJ who's making millions
selling millions of Records known around
the world or lista if he can feel
depressed in his situation in that life
it makes you feel more justified yeah a
little bit any way that you feel do you
think in in the DJ community that
depression and mental health is
something that is should be looked after
a little bit yeah completely yeah I mean
I don't know that much on the matter and
I've never watched the whole documentary
but by all accounts
Tim's manager was meant to be a bit of a
pushy guy I've never seen it now you are
me and just what I've seen and stuff
like that so I can't really comment or
not but I do think the whole mint will
help and I do think it's now like coming
to like the front of things you see a
lot of articles I'm in DJ Mag Mixmag
have done a lot of spreads on on the
whole mental health issues within the
industry on a Luciano was really
but Marilla was really bad I mean we
even had to start the yeah wasn't that
I've hit some sort of depression or
anything like that but I felt like I was
losing my mind because I came back from
tour and I just couldn't adjust back to
normality it wasn't like normal life
that's couldn't get around the jetlag
and I do so far quite bad with it so
you're talking three four days with
absolutely no sleep whatsoever and I
would remember I was sat there watching
like the Shopping Town because that's
all that's on at five in the morning and
some sadly and there's just different
things coming on and I'm sad going the
general I use on my hair [ __ ] right
right okay and I sat ordering things off
eBay that are popping up like differnet
feather dusters and all the whole thing
and honestly right I'll go through it
all and I went out of the house because
the Majel was [ __ ] right and I went that
Asda this is out like 5:00 in the
morning sat on the floor and I was down
in the hair product I try you know every
foot and honestly maybe hair was quite
useful and so then I got up walked off
then the wire was there went and picked
up a t4 dishwasher tablets in a
massively big bit of air properly and
checked out way so they the staff had
have been watching me the most of
thought he is oh it is my living so I've
got out I said what the [ __ ] am I doing
this so go home I was telling all the
lads are like in hysterics I start
ordering dreamcatchers and stuff like
that I'm like not into that [ __ ]
whatsoever and I remember speaking will
air one of the lads Molly and you know
when you're off a bit comes on your
calendar on your iPhone all the products
which are coming and they scroll down
loads over a hundred stuff on order
coming and honestly mate though like
poor Jeremy house was just full of stuff
getting posted through for me be and I
was like what the [ __ ] he make t-shirts
and stuff like that was the most normal
stuff but I must have just been guessing
sizes cause they were like Papa food so
as they started losing a bit and I was
going on like nighttime drives and like
this voice in my head started coming
more
was kind of like the only really gonna
go with sleepers by smashing your car
that lorry across the air or things like
that
and that's when I started thinking
[ __ ] hurling there's something wrong
so I spoke to my mom went to the doctors
and the doctors said like look what kind
of the sleep deprivation is kind of
making you go a bit delusional type of
thing so they put me on some sleeping
tablets which actually had an
antidepressant built into it okay and
that makes you crush before it brings
you back up so I'm feeling loser
and then had like some antipsychotic
drug as well to try and condense the
vices and I was on them for a couple of
mantra and it all my mouth in Miami and
March and you're still trying to take
them when you're on tour because your
body's kind of become used to them and
onto a you hit that many different time
zones that you don't know if you've
taken on one day or not type of thing
and I just remember suck my are week I
don't say I don't need them whatsoever
and I've just train my mind to look
you're jet-lagged you know what I mean
just sit and deal with it
get some sleep when you can't sleep and
like rainy and all them quotes me
through that you've got to learn to
sleep when your body's telling you to
sleep take the thing if you're up all
night then you're up all night you
thought because you know what to say if
you can't sleep then you sitting in you
turn yourself off when you've got an
hour before start work you're not going
to sleep in that hour because you're got
to tell yourself for that whole I want
that you've got to go to sleep in the
hour and then late you shut your eyes in
your late art I'm gonna sleep in for
work and it all just gets on top of you
but on top of that in the DJ world I
mean everyone out there knows how much
drugs is kicking a bulb in the theater
world and how many DJ's are actually
involved and it's tough layouts if
that's what they want to do then let
them do a type of thing but of course
that whole come down area is gonna mess
with people's mind
alcohol is a depressant as it is so much
free alcohol when you DJ every single
pot whether they even you're playing
them on off you know what I mean I could
go and see if DJ for instance like on
Saturday
Danny's playing cosmic I'm already
speaking on a lake or on Twitter earlier
on I might pop down and see him Ben
Nicki's up next next week who I don't
even like I'm not in whose music now
that I don't like it it's just not my
thing
he's already right we're gonna
absolutely I'm gonna say my god he's got
a reputation yeah oh he loves him he's
great kid book like you'll go there gigs
in it's all free alcohol there so you've
got a goes little because it's free you
know I mean so once it gets on that and
then you're rolling and the days your
mind just starts going and it's good to
see that people are picking up on the
the fact that these young kids are
involved in the world and the thrust
from basically nothing into plane in
millions across the year you know I mean
with Lourdes Armani loads of free things
and they just get flown around and of
course that they're gonna get involved
in this world that is essentially gonna
really mess with the heads type of
finian or I mean and even go to a gig
and playing in front of even if you play
in front of a few hundred people go back
to your hotel room on your own you crush
mate like massively because you've been
so high everyone's been they're loving
it you're doing your thing you're loving
the music that you're playing everyone
out there's really enjoying the night
you leave so happy that you want to sit
then talk about it and then you go back
to a lonely hotel room and it's just
pitch black with no music on and it
takes a while I mean even off just
working and bars people who work behind
the bar will take an hour or two it will
shut down when they get in if the music
to be passed and all night just the work
that needs that time for the brain to
switch off so when you've been like the
one who's creating that atmosphere
you're so happy but then you've got no
one to talk about it you just lay our
back on my own again you know what I
mean and then you've got to pick
yourself up to go out the next day to be
like oh this is gonna be amazing and
it's just constant peaks and troughs and
it's just hard to keep on top of our
times you know what I mean I think like
the whole luciana thing he was saying
that he got massively involved in drugs
and things they are and that's probably
the main antagonist of it all
but yeah me I'm glad to see that it is
like really like there's a lot of
attention getting paid on it but I don't
think it's just needs to be spoke about
within the DJ world I think it's the
world all that type of thing people need
to understand that this is it's it's a
major thing going on
and everybody to Noreen but even though
other people might not be doing flights
around the world and playing a DJ gig
and then coming back to be our own
there's people who might live at the
partner that the relationships
degenerating yeah or they might be in a
you know someone who person who doesn't
go with the parents as a dysfunctional
household or someone who does live on
their own the same mechanism that you're
talking about which is impacting on DJ's
which is maybe being catalyzed by higher
highs and then some substances and other
things as well so that's a mechanism
it's a module in the back of our minds
humans desire connection their health
wealth and happiness yeah without all of
those things working in harmony you end
up with a dysfunctional human although
we don't meet and I think like I speak
to a lot of people and all like you know
like some of the lads and things like
that and they'll call like oh you've put
a mint life and and I'm in an unhappy
job and still further I try to encourage
them to say if you aren't happy in life
then leave it do you know what I mean
you can't put a price on happiness so if
you'll like not leave like flake leave
your job take the thing or something
like that you know like you you've got
to figure out what it is brilliant
bringing you down whether it's a
relationship that you your job or
whatever like that the area that you
live in in general I mean it can all be
soared if you just sit there and kind of
figure out a plan of what you're gonna
do but a lot of people just the dorm
don't want to like challenges I mean
that's talking from experience from my
friends take the thing that just want it
and the driver sit back and accept
what's going on and I'm just saying
you're gonna look back and regret it do
you not I mean you really are but I mean
there's nothing that can't be solved and
I'm a true believer not like if you're
coming to speak to me and things like
that you know like we can sit there and
we can talk about it and what can get
through everything that it's causing an
issue with them and you know like a lot
of it is just like the jobs our lives
and things like that but I also tell
them that what you're looking at when
I'm posting things on Instagram Twitter
or what
like that is a lord of [ __ ] [ __ ] do
you not I mean it's to give off that you
are living this amazing life and you're
not and I'm like on the forties all the
time seeing on door up my minded they as
I say Columbia all on door LEL something
like act you know I mean waiting to be
picked up
you know I'm sat here on my own type of
thing it's not like look at me I'm I'm
planning from this among the people take
everything that's just two hours of that
one day type of thing there is selfie of
you on your own in the hope I'll get it
set up I you know forgive itself you
meet you anywhere male 3 you know selfie
yeah yeah but like that's and I think
that is it's a major thing with the
whole of society that do believe that
what these people are posting on social
media is their actual life and it's not
but the problem is that there's an
asymmetry between what we see of other
people and what we know of ourselves yes
right so I get to see the best of
everybody else's life while I watch mine
on the fault from a front row seat that
gets to see all of my blunders yeah all
of them the that time that you tried to
chat up the waitress and you looked
silly and that time that you like didn't
think that you looked very like cool
when you stepped out of the door or that
time way you didn't feel very confident
when whatever like all of those things
everybody that is listening has a front
row seat to you watch it through your
own eyes whether you want to or not
yeah however everybody else you get this
curated very polished very imbalance yes
social media fee yeah and the problem is
that we forget that everybody else is
just as idiotic and just as stupid and
just as insecure as we are yeah
everybody is everyone is Alain de Botton
calls it everybody is eternally flawed
yeah and that is human nature is a is
the beautiful part of human nature
because it is the one thing that makes
us all the same yes the fact that all of
us are fairly messed up in one way or
another we all have our demons that we
need to bear some people have some that
are really bad and some people you know
of fortunately haven't but everyone
should be
everyone should be sympathetic and
empathetic to the rest of humanity
because we're all carrying these sorts
of classes right fully agreed yeah I
don't know I think I think it's
interesting to hear the stories of
someone who is in who is in this world
and from the outside looking in
obviously it's such a aspiration this is
what thousands of probably tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of DJ's
around the world that's what they want
we have that life I enrolled yeah but if
they saw the reality you know usually it
insists on meeting up what they want I
will say like to a lot of the lads that
there's no table set them could do a
couple of them have came away for a
weekend and turn on so there's
absolutely no chance I could do your job
like Nam whatsoever
you tell them the Routan and you tell
them as I was saying earlier when I flew
from Colombia and got up on the Thursday
morning I knew from the Thursday morning
and I wasn't getting to bed until I got
like like asleep at night in a proper
bed when I say getting a bet on she
picked up a couple of on a six-hour
flight runs herself America but you
weren't getting to bed probably
overnight until the Monday night in the
booth or so from novella behind time but
that's from the Thursday morning
stepping out of bed that that was the
last time you were sleeping overnight in
a bed comfortable until the Monday night
and you tell that tears and they just
like no you can keep your job and even I
know it yeah exactly right so I mean
people don't see that people just
honestly just see you playing in front
of X amount of people a truck that
you've released doing well or whatever
like that and they look at that side of
things you know what I mean and a lot of
people and I don't even like the word
it's like they look up like the femme
side of things do you know what I mean
and I don't like it because this isn't
what like that's not what I do a job for
I don't class myself as famous never
once thought I am and never ever will
type of thing I just um
add a flower from Newcastle who's been
lucky enough to to follow his dream and
it's living his dream type of thing and
does a job that he wants to do and I
keep telling myself up because
99% of the population doesn't get to do
us you know I mean they're stuck in a
job that they don't want to do you know
what I mean and I've just been lucky
enough to do what I want to do and it's
just it's allowing me to see the world
as long we do this but the people who
want to do that don't actually
understand like the hard work that goes
into it like my nephew he's really
talented when it comes to music and he
said I want to do this on it and I said
I'll teach other DJ it's not a problem
it you know what I mean but the the the
the part that you can't teach is like
being strong too to make sure you get up
for the flight in the morning to make
sure you're not missing it to make sure
that you are hitting every single gig
and smashing them type of thing to make
sure you are on point to everyone you're
not coming across as ignorant arrogant
anything like that when really it is you
just a bit tired are you're a bit down
on us and fill it up because you've been
away from your family and friends for
the past six weeks type of thing and no
one sees that side of it and I don't
think you can teach people that I've up
the only thing that you can actually do
is probably take them on tour people
which is just gonna cost money you know
yeah yeah do you think that there is a
balanced way to do DJ to life do you
think there is yeah so it's not a lost
cause now no I mean I know a lot of DJ's
Patrick goes Teitur for a while come a
faculty talk for a while Eric goes
t-told for a while loose your does look
like that all and I think what you need
is your needs maybes that one time where
you just completely are like ran down
into the ground do you think that your
hair products and broccoli story might
be that maybe what I thought worse than
that if there's a lower lower than sat
in the middle of a stir with broccoli
and hair products I really fear for you
and the thing is though I don't know if
I could ever goatee tool not because I
love the drink too much
I need drink to get in the vibe yeah it
did not get on stage to get in that
booth okay I need a drink because
so far really parley removes hmm so I
need that and it's a bit of Dutch
courage like some aims are played gigs
and like I'm being sick like seconds
before going on stage type of thing
because of the nerves are too much and
if you watch like this anyone who's
close to me like will understand what
I'm saying
if you if you could see my hand I'm like
not trying to put the USB in and then
out stand there and I'll cough never
ever get a coffee don't smoke another
cigarette in your life so make for me a
vac off my knee from the I've got after
the cold or a flu which only get them
after to us take the thing so I'm stood
then I stopped coughing mid gigging
things like that's because I'm like I'm
nervous
and you'll cease looking around and like
my ex-girlfriend was seeing that she
would always look and he could she said
I knew when you would get nervous on you
and you started panic because you look
around the crowd and a lot for someone
who I know just to look back and give me
some sort of like reassurance I was
always looking for her she said I used
to like be like he needs to see you so
this was like a thoughtful even about
this is take the thing and she's right
yeah you do need that and that that's
why I don't think I could ever stop
fully drinking but yeah there is is that
area where you can't just do just drink
moderately personally yeah
maybe's half a month off and a few weeks
on type of thing time off is perfect
it's perfect
I mean Nelly every DJ produces now so
they need that time off to write the
music in that time off like what I'll do
is hammer the gym so I get in a routine
find the gym is great for my mental in
it's great for the problem like
productivity type of thing and it just
makes me just I bet them you know about
what a lot more than me it releases all
the endorphins and stuff like that
and it just makes me feel really good
about myself take the thing dragging
yourself there it's not how those things
yeah I mean either start this tree gets
moved my first week in six weeks and
obviously I don't ago but luckily enough
I trained warmly best mates and so we go
and he was like just come along even if
it's just for something light it'll get
you back in the routine of it and I'm
just fully in the routine
the thing now so when you off if you do
that you eat well if you constantly [ __ ]
it's gonna bring your down type of thing
and you still in that rot as such and
then your biggest and you just be the
healthiest version that you can't be and
you go away on lake on tour and I mean
if I run myself in at the ground I run
myself into the ground when buffs lake
by all accounts I've never met swim but
he's went to like hammer it for 11
months and then for one one for to
unfuck start the yeah goes away it's
Switzerland it will retreat sits on a
trip transfusion or something the entire
blood transfusion and gets all the
download cleaned I would see if Solomon
does it cuz that bloke is a machine is
he a savage you may who's how this party
or nolan ej and other big christophe
I've just be laughing with their from
comfort just before I came in you know
we're of a borrow from James borrow from
Salado okay he he it's a lot
he's almost looks like a porn fish at
those well oh my god quite you switched
on me easy clever easy out of a guy
anyone who is not following Fischer on
Instagram yes it's not shadow but it is
such as well his Instagram stories that
crease me oh my god
but I would probably sis people that hit
it hard Solomon has to month boy me it
goes forever a half the boys know seen
up video of a beach in on someone's
ironing board in the middle of a kitchen
in Melbourne so I decided behind me what
about those like Italian DJ is that
Danny tonight leader in people like that
like that play life Sam shut up y'all
you just broke the record for it over in
air and Remini I think was all that
sunrise festival right play some reduce
size days long set 36 or so I was at 28
or something like that like for a solo
set something ridiculous or something
but by all accounts you stood there and
he's eaten pasta why he's deep and I
know like when they're Martinez brothers
and all like them do a massive monster
thing in Miami every year and then get
pizza delivered to the club and stuff
laid out
stood in the DJ booth eating pizza and
stuff right out that's like yeah it's
good I'd like really into a lot like I
follow like people who do massive long
sets and cuz I know for what you've been
backup mine I probably broke some of
them supplement links or whatever it was
just at my studio a gentle do not Sunday
from the Friday or something like that
but I just don't realize what there is
when I struck the curtain yeah he's just
cracking up yeah interesting what you
said about the fact that the the balance
that you can get comes from some very
basic things right so you're talking
about making sure you sleeps right your
nutrition yeah having some sort of
exercise having some sort of routine
having some sort of sleep and wake cycle
yep and I was discussing this in
düsseldorf yesterday with a big group of
people in the sales floor and they've
got this really highly charged sales
floor very very high pressure a lot of
them are saying they struggled to turn
off when they go home and downstream
from that some of them were maybe
feeling a little bit down and they had
some some twinges of depression and
anxiety and stuff like that I was like
you would be so surprised to find out
how the strongest most capable people on
the planet can get absolutely
annihilated by bad diet messed up sleep
and not of sunlight yeah
it's not I think because of the way that
social me at that mental health
originally was a little bit stigmatized
now there is this it's okay to talk
campaign and stuff like that which is
going on which half of me likes half of
me likes the fact that there is a social
campaign which encourages people to
openly discuss mental health problems
the other half of me feels like
campaigns like that draw attention to it
in a way which still are highlights that
it is a stigma yeah like that by saying
it's okay to talk it's like you're gonna
just talk like I asked you what you had
for breakfast you don't think of what
should I talk about why I actually add
for bread I say that I have someone else
yeah part of and obviously it's a lot
more difficult for
to mandate the fact that how do you say
everybody just be cool with the fact
that some people have down like periods
where they feel a bit sad that's quite
difficult to actually advertise right
yeah it's okay to talk thing I do get
and I do make sense but if the strongest
people the best performers on the planet
can get taken down by poor food poor
sleep poor training poor nutrition of
course you can as well and what happens
is you manage to simulate or bring on
some sort of psychosis yeah through jet
jet lag and some South American food
yeah and and a bit of bitter DJ like
Anakin and some beers like if that's
happening to you like you know look at
someone who's not managed to get
themselves out of bed or have a good
sleep and wake cycle for a couple of
months yeah and doesn't have any friends
it doesn't have any real sort connection
and things like that like of course
that's gonna take them down
of course from it but the thing that I
think is liberating about this
discussion and there's a great book
which is called it's my guy called
Johann Hari called lost connection right
and Johann is gonna come on eventually
I've said this to the listeners I might
have said this for 18 months but I
promise you I'm gonna get him he is
still in my instagramming books last
connections and he identifies a whole
bunch of different causes of depression
right there environmental not biological
and in those so many of them are fixable
it's like make sure that you get some
sunlight make sure that you see some
nature make sure that you've got someone
to talk to make sure you've got some
work that's meaningful to eat right that
you deal with any childhood trauma
I cook anyway not at least I thought it
was this problem that was mine to bear
that it's like this very unique curse
that was bestowed on me and it's this
problem which only I have and then you
look back in your life I'm in a second
and fast food for a week and I I got
four hours sleep at time maximum yeah
might have been that yeah might not have
been I'm weird there's something
dysphoria and a lot wrong with me it
might just be that I'm not giving myself
the foundation to then have a normal
productive functional life of you of
it sounds like DJing on the road is a
little bit like the perfect storm
yeah to create that completely mess it
really really is really as I mean as I
said problem on your own it's not gonna
help whatsoever you know what I mean
like just even just gone through
security day after day in the airport
you know he's sick of it god it's just
like do you ever sometimes think that
you might not go through the the scanner
so that they'll do a wreck because I'm
just so you go baby I've just got a
fierce with Sanders it's here I've got
it like a wave are on my visa for
America so I've got to go through
secondary immigration there just takes
the ages getting into the country and
then he sat there and the old dead sound
are really sound and then some of them
want to go through the suitcase so pull
everything out then they just leave it
for your pocket and it's kind of like if
that person isn't friendly whether you
call through Security office room
secondary immigration it pisses you off
from day one do you not I mean sat at
home yeah but look at it not can really
aid to the way you're feeling and things
like that then you'll get on a plane and
the plane food will be [ __ ] you'll sit
there and you're getting food and your
whole day is just like this is just a
[ __ ] waste why am i yeah do you
always fly in like good class like add
the long distance runs of nice nice
class yeah we have distance and but do
try and get further the end the shorter
wants to get in if there isn't like a
business class area such would do try
and get like emergency exit just because
I've got a bad lower back my good
friends is that you have been on planes
all this much wanna one Michael friends
the chiropractor just basically well in
the corner and he's kind of he's east
help a lot Bree says I need to work on
it a lot but because you're not here for
a good length of time it's pretty hard
because every work that I'm doing stress
resetting itself under yes he's kind of
like you need to get as much space I
mean if you think about you stood
bending over dangerous yeah I've got a
guy
we'll know dr. stuart mcgill who's the
world's world leading expert on back
pain right I had to go see him in Canada
yeah either fixed George st. Pierre all
the ways you have to eat he's NFL NHL
NBA MMA everything best guys in the plan
yeah I'll put you in touch you look to
it
hero yeah and but yeah you know these
sort of little physiological
psychological effects and you know
you're just going on a plane for a bit
it's like well yeah fine like that
that's great in a normal person's world
like mine where I yesterday I got I went
to düsseldorf and back in a day which is
the only thing weirdly enough before we
do this the only thing that I can
actually kind of start to link in with
what you do yeah it's for flight but
there were 45 minutes each year and
there was a little bit of moving around
the earth through connections and stuff
like that and even that I was like this
is [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah do you have you got
like airplane hack saw like have you got
your favorite way of going through
airports or review your favorite areas
in airports it always goes to look good
enough for your fly and like that much
yeah do get cards for the long just like
my um excoriate isn't a lot of priority
lounges I I'm gonna like a gold member
be so that can get us of any be a lounge
which is kicking around who's collecting
your ad miles you somewhere so what I've
got them all on the BA out somewhere
there you'll be able to buy a house
honestly do not understand how the word
I'm meaning that I don't I'm just me
brother lon he's got loads on being he
keeps like oh yeah got that hotel on
I've got that flight on that in the
miles and that don't understand it just
seemed like it was a circumnavigating
the globe no monthly basis so I like
what what the worst thing about them x1
says I've got to call up and say look so
kind of if I was to take someone see on
that the next long tour yeah I could
like ring hum X and say can you give me
a price using the points type of thing
on this flight on these flights take
things and see what can come up book I
really don't know how it all works myth
no you don't know I'm not invested in
finding up
so you're getting you've managed to make
flying as comfortable as you can though
yes yes yeah I've me system tools about
this game on iPhones it's called wood
block or something like that it's kind
of like Tetris okay but like harder okay
and it Hwang's me up so rotten so I'm
sadly and before I know it I'm like
three hours deeper it will fight and I'm
just playing this game honestly the bet
you've got it like really charge your
phone or I've got an air like a curry on
case which has got it like a one of them
like bat we've like built into a text in
which you can take out like the lithium
battery so I'll sit and have that fully
charged army form fully charged and gone
up in net and there's that strike hero
as well which is kind of like you're a
footballer and you just gotta like draw
the puff of the ball on a Fiona I was
just sitting Elvis estimate I'll get in
there late for four or five hours if
you're flying around America a lot of
the planes have got I am Wi-Fi on all
like like TVs and the selections
brilliant videos of course they've
attempted to try to produce on the plane
I do a lot if I'm got good space but a
lot of the time if like yeah if you're
in the business in business area it's
sound you know meaning you've got your
own area to sit put the laptop on but if
you're putting it on the table in front
you because if you've got it on your lap
you look like up your next pull and it's
killing you straight away so you'll put
it on the table and no matter who you
are the person front you must get a like
it six cents to put the seat back as
soon as you put a laptop on there but
puts a [ __ ] many slams it down so you
trying to produce leg up so I do when
I'm on the road I've doom over in a
hotel room gonna do on the prin and I'll
just sit watch modern family Netflix is
now a thing where you can sit watch it
on there so I'm trying to get it that
minor and stuff like that on there good
yeah it's really really good new series
of top boys coming out at the moment so
you have seen that I've never watched
any of them put it that's been good I've
just been told one air I've just watched
the first episode this is on baby the
BBC one it's called
it's about the soldier who killed
someone like Taliban okay and he got put
in jail for it because it said it was
late in cold blood but then he's just
been that open I've just watched the
first one and real sorry no no yeah and
he's kind of just got with his barrister
and then his barristers been assaulted
and the police I've seen it it's a it's
it looks like really cool so I can't
remember what it's what it's called
looks like really really good one
there's another one wait you've got to
think if you if you end up finding I
don't know like become like a Star Trek
fan yeah if there's ever a day I don't
know think you're fairly safe from this
being the case but if you ever got
really into sci-fi and you didn't speak
to anyone except for DJ for like a
couple of wait here you turn into like a
proper comic-con like Oh honestly that
air I think you were that stranger
things are one that gets me montage I've
like finished the third series I've took
me a while to get through it with all
the traveling the first two series I
watched like within a day type of thing
I watch the first one just all off and
second one as soon as I've got released
i sat in and I remember we had a like
mean like err ex-girlfriend was sat
there and this Irish lad had flown
across to watch me play I think it was
with Sasha and you came on his own and
he tweeted saying that he was across on
his own I was like I'm not letting me
stay in this like my city on your own so
I drove to his hotel picked him up took
him up for food with me in the promoters
and all that beforehand he sat there
like this language of all the lads took
them back to mine for an after pie then
just said you can stay here so he sat up
and stuff like that and then the next
day judgment they got on the fight as I
get the later one we sat and watched
stranger things got like dominoes in and
he was just sat there like that all
through they did and I ran him up to the
airport and he's became like a really
good friend he does a lot of work from
socials and not now and one unbelievable
story yeah he's a lovely kids I'll just
say that you're not sitting in Newcastle
on your room if you've run off on your
own I want to make sure you have the
best your best time yet but yeah it took
me a while to get through the third
series but as soon as it finishes went
straight at you you look three tracks
just like that there's you the
inspiration that gives me is just it's
just really strange strange things quite
so just spooky and very sad
but it's the tension in those seas with
11 in that the mine flare thing and I
just sit there and it just you can just
create like some odd stuff in your head
already right I know exactly what I'm
gonna go do yeah and you make or get all
those darker sounds and stuff like that
man off you go have you got any
restriction now it's obviously one of
the things first off I I don't know what
I would want to make but secondly if I
did I couldn't make it right
is there any restriction now from what
is in your mind to what comes out of the
speakers or what goes into the novice
stunts so you can make whatever they
sounded they were fair we've actually
been opened
like left on an 800 for instance we've
all run back and all alight so they come
out all right stomach in the studio and
I like them sick a right in lake house
techno vibes do you not I mean I want to
air I'll write something different and I
was just I said with one of the kids
also say what big up a minute and one of
the live shows up which was a odd Rick
so I don't listen to one of Drake's
trucks and I was just like it was 10
minutes and sat there and how to draw
straight a wrinkle not like hell and I
was just like the bass lines piss easy
suck they all have this loop corn
inflate four and release just dissected
Drake's
try some ones they went out so you go on
and you can buy like silly little hip
hop vocals and things like that off so I
heard it move blake create this
three-and-a-half minute hip hop try them
or got it in the cars and stuff saintly
an hour right leg down temp or stuff and
i might put something on there on my
facebook or while ago and there is a
producer from down liverpool he popped
up and said there's a pop producer dying
to get out of you i'm telling you me
mmm-hmm maybe an angle or somebody look
at in the futures gonna say would you
ever be interested in doing something
like that or i remember I can't remember
the film but deadmau5 did the entire
soundtrack for a film within the last
couple of years yeah I mean I'm good
friends with a dirty south of you
remember him an Australian guy
believable no he's from Eastern Europe
somewhere but he lives in Australia now
in Melbourne and he sounds like he
scores a lot of a lot of films do you
know I mean I think there's a lot of
sound engineer yeah and he will just
just wait it from start finish all the
score for the film
that'd be something again serious more
you know it's not there's no on the road
either because a lot sick
I'll probably just throw the pot job you
know how to do it there we go yeah I
mean they're taking money back yeah so
what's next what's happening what's the
rest of 2019 going to store for you yeah
so for the next couple of weeks I'll be
sat in the studio probably catching up
with friends when I can get the most and
family and stuff like that
probably just hitting a few bars and
tongue and then there has a seat just
hammer in the studio I want to get
when's my next gig beginning October
that gives me to only get maybe four or
five trucks ready for the beginning of
October I've got two gigs down on wheels
so on to get about four or five trucks
ready for them a test out and I've got
another two weeks off which is while a
de zon never have a goal that's just
gonna be yeah Lord just Soros was too
mad like just really bad for you so that
doesn't it's just I just find it Mart
and then I go across to America as I say
and come straight but do Manchester than
straight on to India then to New Zealand
Australia body Australia then back and
do Leeds Liverpool and and come back
home and that takes me to the beginning
December so I'm gonna have to get a lot
of music prepared for them even if it's
just ideas ready pencil to finish on the
road or whatever like that I'll start a
lot on the road and I'll finish that
again through December Marine Air New
Year people want to see you played this
new year me released it yet I haven't
released it's all I've seen America yeah
and then yeah Macross therefore for then
and then the phone call before was
started off Rennie was basically seeing
that I'm across there for New Year then
I come back then I'm a cost of Dominican
Republic to do like the do this
across America called holy ship Yassine
it's a huge cruise liner festival yeah
and now they've changed they're like
holy Sh oh go ship and have change that
the ghost ship wrecked the holy ship
wrecked so now actually on land which is
a five their party in an all-inclusive
resort Dominican Republic and the sand
and the likes of me scream and people
like that
see you're coming back but if we leave
I'm probably get a job behind that's
young tell me and then it looks like
straight from that industry open to
America around America and there he was
seeing there that I could be a fingers
for like six weeks because it's gonna
take all the way through February in
March and then it's Miami and March on
me as well be over this all could well
be away from January till end a march
type of thing probably coolest better
places in love
it's like worst places sorry than
America isn't that unsolicited to be
based for a bit and then release why's
this I mean I'm something so much music
me like ridiculous amount new stuff of
remixes bootleg half enough remixes for
the year yeah oh it does
I've seen it I've seen a lot recently
let's and stuff like yes so now this is
all like brand-new original so I think
the next one could be maybe a two track
EP let's go sake is it but back in the
day a lot of your releases were centered
around or at least when kind of Pepsi
and Gophers and stuff like that were
coming out a lot of them were centered
around two trackers
yes ranked as a detractors it's been at
least in terms of what I see more
singles yes Lee yeah have you got that
would you ever do like a full album i
watch i mean i've went to the team and
that spoke about doing maybe like
another kind of conceptual album project
maybe nine trucks or even three releases
of five generally means sauce like
fifteen tracks that I'm putting out and
at the end of the fifteen I'll do like a
huge like continuous mix but also in
between the mixes I'll do kind of like a
synth work in there to make it just a
one-off performance type of things so
people you've got this mix book a small
time singles are the ones which are
perform invest and that's what the
performed best on the lakes would be
port which promoters of people are going
off so if you're constantly getting to
number one which a lot of my releases on
the probe charts it's good like yeah if
you release a three trucker it goes into
more of the release charts and people
buy the releases of all rather than
specific trucks I don't fully understand
that side of things that's me management
telling me what's going on then I mean
it's Eric and like our manager make you
is saying like release one truck at a
time it's coming out on a label which is
owned by Eric I'll be laying if if I
kind of trust you me so it's all good so
yeah I am looking at other labels
measure the labels out there which are
on a work before love to release on
Solomon's label dynamic and I mean I've
already done Sasha's and dig weeds which
was a big target of mine and what's left
anything any other ones like you
probably just sovereigns may be honest
with you yeah what if you listening so
on them I ever get his on Big Lots man
it's been fantastic yeah I really I
share it's been awesome got a cut short
one next time you hear let me know
anyone who wants to follow you online
we're sure they had a Twitter on
Instagram as Kristoff music chef
Facebook's Kristoff music and SoundCloud
is Kristoff music as well we spelled
Kristoff C or I stlp H think a lot of it
people misspell it and stuff like that
visit the whole number of ways that
people can ruin your eyes it's name yeah
I think it goes to audible like
autocorrect on our phones and things
like that I'd say H after the see I sort
of keep telling myself oh yeah anyway
man thank you so much for your time
[Music]
you